the states that have chosen to not cover
to not expand care to our lower-income
Americans Americans that are most
vulnerable include Alabama is that
correct mr. saucy that's correct
Florida that's correct Kansas that's
correct
Mississippi that's correct Missouri
correct North Carolina correct South
Carolina
correct Oklahoma correct South Dakota
correct
Tennessee correct Texas correct
Wisconsin correct
Wyoming correct these are the states
that have chosen not to cover the most
vulnerable Americans correct that's
right and these are the states that are
also we're seeing a lot of their
representation trying to combat the ACA
when they're not even buying into it to
protect their own correct that's we're
talking about 2.5 million people who
don't have courage because they have not
explained Dominican why do you think
they are doing that well I you know I
still work with the governor's on this
very question and the the truth to that
answer is because it was tainted as
Obamacare and it was a completely
political decision so people are not
getting insurance in these states for
political reasons that's your assessment
absolutely